das sowjetische Ehrenmal in Berlin zum
jahrestag des Sieges der Roten Armee
über Nazi Deutschland haben sich
hunderte Menschen versammelt gedenken
mit den Fahnen des untergegangenen
sowjetdreichs aber für viele geht es
hier vor allem darum Russland und seinem
Präsidenten zu feiern da macht er schon
richtig warum macht er das richtig ja
weil das ist ja die verschiedensten
Ukraine ist ziemlich viel verbreitet
Russland eigentlich hat befreit von
Faschismus von Narzissmus und jetzt
kämpft wieder leider allein die früher
warum leider alleine
Spieß ist selbst Russlanddeutsche sie
ist gegen den Krieg und gegen Putin ihre
Haltung provoziert
wollen sie mir den Mund verbieten
mit ihrer Meinung ist sie hier allein
die Regierung in der Ukraine muss man
auswechseln und in Russland nicht nein
der russische Präsident ist der beste
der Krieg in der Ukraine spaltet die
russische Community in Deutschland
wir sind nicht für den Krieg und ich
weiß dass wir hier einfach laut bleiben
müssen damit wir nicht durch diese
lauten provokativen Menschen definiert
werden der Krieg in der Ukraine hat Dara
Kosok Spieß kämpferisch gemacht sie hat
Politikwissenschaften studiert ist bei
den Berliner Grünen mit acht Jahren kam
sie mit ihrer Mutter Valentina aus
Kasachstan nach Berlin seit Kriegsbeginn
hat sich der Ton zwischen Mutter und
Tochter verschärft sie steht richtig auf
diese ukrainische Seite aber meine
Bekannte sie stehen nur auf die
russlandseite aber trotzdem ich rede mit
diese Leute ja ich wollte nicht
fein sein
ich nehme das einfach so
der Großvater von Valentina Spies starb
im Krieg gegen Nazi Deutschland die
Geschichte der Russlanddeutschen ist von
Tod Vertreibung und Verfolgung geprägt
unter Stalin wurden die Deutschen als
Faschisten deportiert den deutschen
galten die Spätaussiedler als Russen
Mutter Valentina hat Angst dass der
Krieg sie nun wieder diffamiert wegen
dieses Krieg
es ist wieder die alle Russlanddeutsche
sie müssen wieder das alles beweisen
dass wir sind ganz andere wir sind gut
wir sind fleißig wir müssen wieder
neue starten das ist so das ist meine
Meinung nach
etwa 3,5 Millionen Menschen leben als
Spätaussiedler jüdische
Kontingentflüchtlinge Zuwanderer in
Deutschland
Meinungsumfragen über diese Menschen
gibt es kaum experten halten eine
größere Gruppe für Pro russisch
eingestellt
die Größenordnung zum Beispiel wird uns
gegeben durch eine Umfrage des
integrationsbarometers schon vor dem
Krieg entstanden aber durchaus noch
relevant die ermittelte dass das etwa
ein Viertel der Russlanddeutschen
Spätaussiedler den Medien aus dem
Herkunftsland also in dem Fall aus
Russland Vertrauen schenkt und die
Vermutung nahe liegt dass diejenigen
dann dann vermutlich auch eher aufgrund
dieses Vertrauens der russischen
Sichtweise Zuneigung
Chorweiler ein Stadtteil im Norden von
Köln 12.000 Russlanddeutsche leben hier
klein Moskau wird der Stadtteil genannt
eine Bürgerinitiative hilft seit
Kriegsbeginn den Flüchtenden aus der
Ukraine
Olga ist eine von ihnen sie lebt seit
Jahrzehnten mit ihrer Familie in Köln
Chorweiler
dreimal in der Woche versorgt die Mutter
von vier Kindern die kriegst
traumatisierten Menschen
für mich Russen und Ukrainer das ist ein
Volk und dann habe ich diese Menschen
gesehen die Leiden die von dem Krieg
laufen flüchten fliehen also ich wollte
Mitte drin sein ich wollte helfen
Olga hilft hier um irgendetwas tun zu
können für die Menschen aus der Ukraine
für diesen Krieg den sie nicht will
fühlt sich die Russlanddeutsche
verantwortlich gemacht diese ganze
anfeinden also das druckt das druckt
auch zu Hause und
wenn man die Kinder zum zu mir kommen
sagen mama was ist denn bei uns falsch
was was was ist denn mit uns nicht so
richtig dass wir jetzt irgendwo wenn wir
russisch draußen sprechen und dann
werden wir sofort so angeguckt und die
andere Kinder sagen auch Russen gehen
oder so das ist das ist sehr schwer
Roman Friedrich ist Streetworker und
selbst Russlanddeutscher er ist besorgt
über die Anfeindungen der Sozialarbeiter
hat eine whatsapp-gruppe gegründet an
die sich betroffene Eltern wenden können
hier hat es seit 14-jähriges Mädchen
bekommen in diesem Zettel mit
Aufforderung die Schule und auch das
Land zu verlassen
[Musik]
es ist nicht nur putinische Propaganda
wenn Menschen sich
unwohl fühlen wenn sich Menschen
irgendwo vielleicht in die Ecke gestellt
fühlen angefeindet fühlen die realen
dokumentierten Fälle die gibt es und
jeder davon ist einer zu viel weil es ja
weil es nicht angeht Menschen aufgrund
ihrer ihrer tatsächlichen oder
vermeintlichen Herkunft politisch in die
Verantwortung zu nehmen im
ältesten amateur-box-club Deutschlands
in Köln tragen auch Russlanddeutsche
ihre Kämpfe aus sie kommen aus
Kasachstan Usbekistan Russland und der
Ukraine
ich bin russlanddeutsch aus Sibirien
gekommen und ich weiß selber was ich
heiße Integration also da war Jungs ist
das Mensch ist Mensch egal von welcher
Nationalität ist
Konflikte zu lösen das lernen Sie hier
jeden Tag in diesem Club wird vielen
geholfen auch ukrainische
Flüchtlingskinder trainieren inzwischen
hier alle Boxen nach sportlichen Regeln
manchmal spielt große Rolle eine Schritt
nach hinten zu machen oder zwei Schritte
nach hinten und nochmal Situation zu
beschauen und beste
Variante zu finden genau darum geht es
die eigenen Positionen zu hinterfragen
nicht nur beim Boxen sondern auch jetzt
in den Zeiten des Kriegs wer steht wo in
der russischen Community Dara beobachtet
in den sozialen Netzwerken wie bestimmte
Gruppen mit fake-einträgen vor allem
einem dienen Putins Krieg zu
rechtfertigen und die Gesellschaft
weiter zu spalten
das ist auch unser Verschulden dass wir
hier zum Teil Menschen haben die dieser
russischen Propaganda glauben obwohl
ihre Kinder das nicht tun bei ihre
Kinder ich eingeschlossen
das irgendwann gesagt haben ich spreche
mit den bekannten meiner Mutter nicht
mehr über Politik ich möchte mich damit
nicht mehr auseinandersetzen und das
können wir uns nicht mehr leisten wir
müssen darüber sprechen was die
Grundlage unseres Zusammenlebens in
Deutschland ist weil wir eben in
Deutschland leben und nicht in Russland